[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في غضون يومين فقط تم الاعلان في
مصر عن وفاه ثلاثه معتقلين معارضين لنظام
السيسي داخل السجون قالت منظمات حقوقيه
انها بسبب الاهمال الطبي لكي يضاف الثلاث
هؤلاء الى قائمه تشمل ازيدا من 260 معتقلا
توفوا رهن الاعتقال من جراء التعذيب او
الحرمان من الرعايه الصحيه منذ انقلاب
الثالث من يوليو من عام 2013 نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين
اين ينتهي حدود العقاب وتبدا مسؤوليه
حمايه سلامه المعتقلين رهن الاحتجاز
والى اي ماذا يمكن تبرير انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان بذريعه مكافحه التطرف والارهاب
اذا يشير تزايد حالات الوفاء المعلن عنها
للعديد من المعتقلين المعارضين في السجون
المصريه يشير الى تفاقم اوضاع الاحتجاز
التي يعيشها المعارضون للنظام الحالي في
مصر فبالاضافه الى التقارير الحقوقيه التي
تحذر من تدهور وضع حقوق الانسان والحريات
العامه في مصر منذ انقلاب الثالث من يوليو
عام 2013 تكشف شهادات المعتقلين وتقرير
منظمات حقوق الانسان عن اوضاع مزريه في
السجون وفي مقر الاحتجاز المصريه تتراوح
بين التعذيب وسوء اوضاع الحبس الى الاهمال
والحرمان من العلاج الطبي
لم ترتبط المرحله التي ابتلت انقلاب
الثالث من يوليو عام 2013 في مصر فقط
بالاعتقالات السياسيه لمعارض النظام انما
ارتبطت ايضا بوفاه المحتجزين
رهن الاعتقال وذكر ان عددهم منذ تاريخ
الانقلاب بلغ نحو 262
وتتحدث المنظمات العربيه لحقوق الانسان في
بريطانيا الان عن وفاه ثلاثه معتقلين يومي
الاول والثاني من اغسطس نتيجه حاله
الاهمال الطبي السائد بالمعتقلات وان
السلطات تعزز من سياسه افلات رجال الامن
من العقاب بدلا من اجراء تحقيقات شاده
فيما جرى واتخاذ تدابير جاده لمنع تكرارها
ويخشى ان تكون حياه عشرات الالاف في هذه
السجون مهدده بشكل او باخر
طالما انتقدت الاداره الامريكيه ونشطاء
امريكيون انتهاكات نظام الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي للمبادئ الاساسيه للديمقراطيه وسجل
حقوق الانسان في مصر ووصفت احكام الاعدام
الجماعيه الصادره بحق الرئيس المعزول محمد
مرسي واخرين بانها تضر بسياده القانون
وتحوله من اداه للعداله الى اداه للقمع
ودع الكونغرس الامريكي اكثر من مره اداره
اوباما للضغط على نظام السيسي لاجراء
اصلاحات في المجالين لكن الدلائل المختلفه
الراهنه تشير الى انه رغم تلك المواقف
وتشديد اداره الرئيس اوباما مع حلفاء
امريكا والاوروبيين وغيرهم على الايثاء
بمبادئ الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان كشرط
لامتداد وتطوير التعاون مع الدول الا انها
لم تستخدم ذات الاسلوب في تعاملها مع نظام
السيسي لوضع حد لممارساته تلك مما جعله
يمضي على ذات النهج بل قفزت واشنطن فوق
ذلك لتجري الان حوارا استراتيجيا مع مصر
يقوده وزير خارجيتها هو الاول من نوعه منذ
6 سنوات وتقدم لها طائرات اف 16 دون
الحصول على اي التزامات تتعلق بالامرين من
نظام السيسي وغير ذلك من جوانب الدعم
الاخرى خاصه فيما يتعلق بعنوان الحرب على
الارهاب ويطرح الامر اسئله مريبه حول
الاستراتيجيات المعلنه وغير المعلن
لامريكا وحلفائها وهل استطاع نظام السيسي
اقناعهم بغض الطرف عن سجله في مجال
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان مقابل عنوان
مكافحه الارهاب الفضفاض والى متى يمكن ان
يستمر هذا الوضع
حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من لندن عمر
عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم
السياسيه في جامعه اكسل البريطانيه ومن
اسطنبول احمد مفرح المتحدث باسمه منظمه
الكرامه لحقوق الانسان ومن القاهره عبر
الهاتف الدكتور حسن نافعه استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه القاهره دكتور حسن
نافعه ما الرد على هذه الاتهامات وهل من
محاسبه جرت حتى الان
يعني انا لست في وضع يسمح لي ان اتاكد من
صحه هذه المعلومات لكن من المؤكد ان هناك
انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان في نفسه والمجلس
المصري لحقوق الانسان نفسه في بعض
التقارير يعني مدد بحاله السجون المصريه
وبوقائع التعذيب لكن
في وضع يسمح لي بالحديث عن
الى اي مدى تف
اقم ولكن في جميع الاحوال
ممكن تبرير اي
انت عندما تتعلق هذه الانتهاكات بقضايا
التعذيب لان التعذيب لا يمكن تبريره باي
حال من الاحوال او تتعلق
لان المعتقل هو انسان يجب على حياته وهذه
مسؤوليه السلطات التي تقوم باعتقال هؤلاء
الاشخاص وحتى لو كان هناك يعني حرب ضد
الارهاب
يجب ان يطبق
على اي انسان يحترم نفسه ان يقبل بانه
تمتلك حقوق الانسان لان هناك ارهاب يتعين
من المحاربته لان الانتهاكات بحقوق
الانسان هي نفسها احد معامل تفريخ الارهاب
في المستقبل وبالتالي هذا السلاح يحدده
ولكن دكتور ليس هنالك ضغط جدي من قبل
المجتمع المصري نفسه من مثقفين ومن يقولون
انهم حقوقيون ومن اساتذه ومن مجتمع مدني
حتى يجري تحقيق في هذه اذا كانت تقول
السلطاتنا مجرد مزاعم فلتثبت ذلك فليجري
التحقيق حتى انت مثلا معنا الان تتاكد من
هذه المعلومه انت نفسك مثلا الان لا تعرف
ان كان هذا صحيح ام لا هل هذا صحي وهل هذا
يعني منطقي
ان حاله الاست غفار في التي
المجتمع
والتقلبات العنيفه التي شهدتها مسلم لثوره
25 يناير ثم عندما تولد جماعه الاخوان
للسلطه هناك حالات انتقام سياسي يعني
تستخدم لتبرير هذه الالتهابات المستمره في
واقع الامر منذ ثوره 25 يناير سقط كثيرون
جدا ضحايا القتل او ضحايا عمليات البلطجه
ولم تحدث تحقيقات عن السجون دكتور
اتحدث اتحدث عن السجون تحديدا لانه يقال
ان هنالك اكثر من
260 حاله اما قتل تحت التعذيب او بسبب
الاهمال او بسبب حرمان من العلاج الطبي
هذا يحدث في السجون المصريه تحديدا بعد
بعد 30 من يونيو او الثالث من يوليو 2013
لا يستطيع شخص مثلي ان يؤكدها او يمشيها
وهذا ما اسالك عن الدكتور لماذا لا
تطالبون بالتحقيق بهذه الانباء خاصه ان
هنالك منظمات تقول انها وثقتها مثل
المناظره حقوق الانسان في لندن
وهنالك اسماء ذكر الدكتور
تحقيق
مستقله
يعني
التاكد من صحه الاتهامات المنسوبه ومحاكمه
او انزال
العقاري من يرتكب هذه الانتهاكات نحن قمنا
بواجبنا لكنني انا شخصيا لست عضوا في مجلس
حقوق الانسان لكن لو تراجعين كتاباتي سوف
تلاحظين انني يعني باستمرار
طالب بتشكيل ميدان تحقيق في كل مره تحدث
فيها انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان سواء
في مصر او في اي مكان اخر في العالم
سيد عمر عاشور ضيفي من لندن ما المسؤوليه
القانونيه امام اي سلطه حاكمه تجاه هكذا
اتهامات برايك
طبعا توجد مشكله يعني قانونيه ولكن
المشكله الحقيقيه هي ان الفتره التي تلت
انطفات يناير 2011 وما بين 2011 و20 يوليو
2013 هذه الفتره كانت تشمل العديد من
الحريات السياسيه كانت تشمل نزاهه الى حد
ما في الصندوق وكانت تشمل فكره تحسين او
اصلاح القطاع الامني بما فيه
مراقبه قطاع السجون لانه تاريخ يعني طويل
في مساله الانتهاكات ومساله
يعني عدم مراعاه حقوق السجناء وحقوق
المعتقلين
وكانت هناك العديد من المبادرات يعني
تبناها البعض في البرلمان تبنتها العديد
من المنظمات المجتمع المدني المصريه
تبناها العديد من الحقوقيين تبانها حتى
بعض ضباط الشرطه الذين كانوا منخرطين في
عمليه الاصلاح القطاع الامني من الداخل
ليس بشكل رسمي ولكن بشكل مبادرات شخصيه او
بتنظيمات غير تابعه للدوله كالتلاف العامل
الضباط الشرطه مثلا ثم بعد ذلك بعد يولي
كل هذا الكلام
الاطار الان اطار مختلف تماما انت لديك
سلطه مستشرسه في مواجهه كل من تعتقد انه
يعارضها او يخالفها بطريقه اخرى وتستبيح
في ذلك كافه الانتاجات سواء كان داخل
السجون او حتى خارج السجون من خلال القمع
المعارضه بشكل عام سواء المعارضه
المؤسستيه او المعارضه التي وجدت نفسها
خارج الاطار المؤسساتي حاليا
احمد مفرح ضيفي من اسطنبول كيف يمكن كيف
يمكن ايقاف ما يسمى في بعض تقارير منظمات
جنازات السجون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
للاسف الشديد خلال الفتره الماضيه وخصوصا
من بعد 30 يونيو حتى الان ونحن نتعامل مع
نوع من انواع الانتهاكات تحولت الى جرائم
ترتكب بحق المواطنين المصريين المعتقلين
منهم السياسيين بداخل مراكز الاحتكاك وهو
الامر الذي ادى الى مقتل حتى الان ما لا
يقل عن 285 حاله وهي ما قمنا بتوثيقها ليس
فقط 260 اليوم بهذه الحاله نتحدث عن 285
حاله وفاه داخل مراكز الاحتجاز جره
التعذيب المفضي الى الموت او
المعيشه الغير طبيعيه داخل مراكز احتجاز
او سوق الرعايه الصحيه المتعمده بشكل كبير
والتي تؤدي الى الوفاه الامر للاسف الشديد
يعني يؤثر بشكل واضح وبشكل فاضح بشكل كبير
على الحق في الحياه للموطنين المصريين
وبالتالي فنحن ايذاء مثل هذه الجرائم
وايذاء مثل هذه
بحق المعتقلين سيكون من الصعوبه بمكان ان
نتخيل انه ستاتي فتره من الفترات في ظل
وجود هذا الدعم السياسي لمنتسبي جهاز
الجيش والشرطه في تعاملتهم مع المعتقلين
من قبل الهرم التنفيذي او الرئيس الهرم
التنفيذي والسلطه التنفيذيه مباشره في
تعاملاتها مع هذا الامر خصوصا وانه لا
توجد حاله من حالات التحقيقات التحقيقات
الجلديه التي تمت في مقتل هؤلاء 285 حتى
الان وكل التحقيقات التي اجريت حتى الان
منذ 30 يونيو تتهم يا اما
للاسف الشديد الدوره الدمويه انخفاض
الدوره الدمويه في قتلها لهؤلاء المعتقلين
او بسبب سوء الاحوال المعيشيه داخل السجون
وان السجون وهو الامر الذي صراحه يعني
نستغربه بشده حينما تكون السجون مكتظه ولا
يوجد مكان
لكي يسع هؤلاء المعتقلين بداخل مراكز
الاحتكاك الشرطه فمن هو المسؤول طيب هل
هذا الامر مقصود كما قلت هذا كما قلت تحول
من الانتهاك الى الجريمه هناك الان جريمه
منظمه ترتكبها السلطات المصريه بحق
المعتقلين داخل مراكز الاحتجاز تحولت هذه
الجريمه وافرزت عن وجود 285 حاله وفاه
داخل مراكز احتجاز حتى الان في ظل وجود
الان نتخيل ونعتقد طبقا لتقاريرنا اكثر من
19 الف محتجز داخل المراكز الاحتجاز اكثر
من 50 الف معتقل اعتقلوا منذ 30 يونيو حتى
الان اكثر من 42 مركز احتجاز رسمي واكثر
من 325 مركز احتجاز غير رسمي وجد فيها
المعتقلين في مصر وبالتالي كل هذه الارقام
تعطينا هذه الدلاله دلاله انه اصبح امرا
اصبحت هناك حاله من حالات القتل البطيء
للمعتقلين بداخل مراكز الاحتجاز وهو ما
نشهده فعليا في بعض المراكز الاحتجاز بشكل
صارخ حينما يكون اللواء حسن السوهاجي وهو
مدير مصلحه السجون في مصر الان يرتكب في
حاله قتل منذ مارس الماضي وحتى الان ويقوم
بالاشراف على تعذيب المعتقلين بداخل سجن
العقرب وغيره فهذا امر ممنهج حينما يكون
في عهد اللواء مجدي عبد الغفار سته وخمسين
حاله وفاه منذ مارس منذ اتى فهو امر ممنهج
حينما ياتي السيسي ومنذ ان قام السيسي
ومجلس على الكرسي في مصر 156 حاله وفاه
للمعتقلين فقط داخل فهو امره
التي اتوضا لا وجود للتحقيقات اتوقف مع
عمر عاشور بسؤال سريع سيد عمر عاشور ما
زودنا به سيد مفرح من ارقام واسماء وما
الى ذلك يجري دائما انكاره من اي مسؤول في
النظام المصري الحالي او من متبني لوجهه
نظر هذا النظام او مدافع عنه كيف يمكن
تخطي حاله الانكار هذه على الاقل حتى يعرف
الخيط الابيض من الخيط الاسود وحتى تعالج
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان بجديه وانسانيه
تخطي حاله الانكار عندما
تتغير اراده السياسيه وتتغير القياده
السياسيه لان واضح ان الاراده حاليا هي
انكار كل ما يحدث انكار كل السلبيات لا
توجد في مصر اي مشاكل يعني راينا حاله
متدهوره للامن مثلا في سيناء وقيادات تخرج
وتقول الامر مستقره تماما وكلمه تحت
السيطره غير كافيه راينا ايضا يعني اليوم
وزير الخارجيه المصري في مؤتمر صحفي معلن
يعني اساله مراسل نيويورك تايمز عن بعض
الانتهاكات والانتهاكات ضد الصحفيين التي
تحدث وهو ينكر تماما ان هناك التهاجد
الصحفيين يعني يعتبر انهم ان هؤلاء
ارهابيين او متهمين بالارهاب وبالتالي
عليهم ان يدفعوا ثمن فيوجد حاله مستمره من
الانكار نحن لا توجد برلمان لا يوجد يعني
قضاء بالقوه الكافيه التي تخرج وتحاسب لا
يوجد اعلام حر في في الفتره الحاليه ففتره
الحريات السياسيه التي كانت تتيح مثل هذه
المراقبه ومثل هذه المحاسبه سواء من داخل
المؤ الدوله كبرلمان ومجالس حقوق الانسان
وغيرها او من خارج مؤسسات الدوله
كاعلاميين وقضاه مجتمع مدني الان اصبحت
غير متاحه او متعرضه للقصف الرسمي الشديد
او القمع الرسمي الشديد وبالتالي يعني
الوضع اصعب بكثير ويمكن لهذا الانكار ان
يستمر المراقبه الوحيده التي تحدث من
الخارج يعني تجد بعض البيانات التي تخرج
من الخارج من المنظمات الحقيقيه التي
تتابع من الخارج
تستطيع ان تتنفس وتسلط الضوء لكنها لا
تستطيع ان تحاسب لا تستطيع فقط ان تكشف ما
يحدث اما المحاسبه فليس فلا تستطيع ان
تفعل ذلك في الوقت الحالي
او معنى ضيوف الكرام وابقوا معنا مشاهدينا
الكرام فاصل قصير نعود بعده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى الدكتور نافع
دكتور
ستهورات نصفهم ديمقراطيون ونصفهم جمهوريون
طالبوا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري
قبيل الحوار الاستراتيجي مع الامريكي مع
مصر بضروره فتح ملف انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
والاصلاح السياسي
ما قولك
السؤال موجهين نعم دكتور تفضل
اي تدخل خارجي في ملف حقوق الانسان يعقد
حقوق الانسان
وسجل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس سجلا
يعني مشرقا في مجال الدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان وتاريخ الولايات المتحده كله
وتاريخ تعامل مع نظم دكتاتوريه في كل
انحاء العالم وخصوصا عندما تكون المساله
متعلقه بشراع سياسي في الداخل انظر الى
الامريكي كيف تحول
في محاوله للضغط
وعقوبات عسكريه او اقتصاديه معينه الا
تحول كامل في
الحكومه على المصالح وتستخدم قضيه حقوق
الانسان في واقعه الامر عندما تخدم هذه
المصالح لكن عندما تتعارض مع هذه المصالح
سيتم التضحيه بحقوق الانسان
الذي يجب ان نتعلمه من تاريخ العلاقات
الدوليه من
يعني التاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هنا هنا بالتحديد في هذه النقطه التي اشرت
اليها وهي يعني فيها من المنطق بان
الولايات المتحده عندما يناسبها الامر
تتحدث عن انتهاكات حقوق الانسان وعندما لا
يناسبها لا تتحدث عنها لكن في الحالتين
يكون يوجد انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان فان
نظام السوداني مثلا لا يعجبها البشير تقول
انه يعني ترفع من العقوبات تحت حجره حقوق
الانسان لكن هي اصحاب مع نظام السيسي اذا
لا مشكله مع انتهاكات حقوق الانسان يعني
بس بالحالتين موجوده انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان
السودانيه في لحظه من اللحظات عندما كان
هناك تباين بين الموقف الامريكي تجاه
السودان كان الضغط يتم من خلال محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه وكان هناك
ان يسلم
الرئيس البشير نفسه للمحكمه دكتور
يعني اعطى
تفاصيلتهم يعني انا اختصرت لك الفكره التي
تفضلت بها عن انه فعلا يستخدمونها متى
يريدون ومتى لا يريدون لكن في الحالتين
يكون هنالك فعلا انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وهنا دكتور عمر عاشور سؤالي لك عندما يجري
استخدام حقوق الانسان
لغايه في نفس يعقوب الى اي حد يمكن ان
يسيء ذلك الى مفهوم الدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان وتصبح يعني بلا بلا رهبه مساله
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
يعني هتوجد تشكليه حقيقيه مع الولايات
المتحده ودعمها اما الاستبداد مصلحيا واما
الديمقراطيه مصلحيا واما الديمقراطيه في
حالات قليله جدا مبدئيا
اشكاليه الاستبداد يعني كانت الجمله
الشهيره التي هو عباره روسف الشهيره كان
يتعامل مع السموذج نظام السموذ في 39 كان
يقول يعني هم اشرار ولكنهم اشرارنا يعني
كان يستخدم لفظ اقبح بكثير من الاشرار
لكنهم هم هم الاشرار الذين نمتلكهم هذه
كانت السياسه وكانت سياسه الديمقراطيين
بشكل يعني ديموقراطيين كما يتعاونونجمتين
مع هذه السياسه كارتر المثال الشهير الاخر
كان مع شاهي ايران يعتبر ان في 78 انه
واحه الاستقرار والامان في الشرق الاوسط
قبل الثوره بسنه واحده
وبالانتهاكات التي كان يفعلها الشاه
له كلمه شهيره ايضا حين قال ان بعض
الانقلاب ان العسكر سيقولون لمصر الى
الديمقراطيه وكانت كلمه يعني لا ادري من
اين اتى بها وايت حالات تاريخيه تدعم ذلك
لا يوجد يعني
ولكن كان هناك تغير في مثل هذه السياسه في
مساله دعم الاستبداد كمصلحه امريكيه
لتحقيق اما امن الحلفاء كاسرائيل او
الاستقرار في المنطقه الذي يعني يؤمن خطوط
النفط ويؤمن الاستثمار او لان الاستبداد
يعني له يد قويه في مواجهه الارهاب واذا
كان استبدادا مواليا فسيكون يعني يد اقوى
للولايات المتحده ضد مساله الارهاب تغيرت
هذه السياسه الى شكل ما في عهد جورج بوش
بعد 11 سبتمبر كانت النظره هنا ان
المهاجمين 19 كلهم اتوا من من ديكتاتوريات
من انظمه استبداديه والاستبداد افرخ
الارهاب وبالتالي في على المدى
الاستراتيجي ليس على المدى القصيره او
المتوسط على المدى الطويل يجب ان تكون
هناك في دم اجنده او او يعني اجنده حوريات
لدعم الديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط حين تم
الدفع بهذه الاجنده في 2004 اتت ب 88
النائب للاخوان في مصر 2005 اتت بحماس في
2006 فاذا الديمقراطيه اتت
بكيانات او احزاب او طيارات ليست بالحليفه
الولايات المتحده فكان هناك
ايضا استقطاب في في الحاله العراقيه واستر
في الحاله الافغانيه فكان هناك تراجع الى
حد ما في هذه الاجنده ونظره ان يجب ان
نعود الى فكره الاستبداد لانه سيحقق على
الاقل المصلحه على المدى القصير وبعد اربع
سنوات سيتغير رئيس وستكون مشكله رئيس اخر
او اداره اخرى
الذي هز الموضوع حدث في 2011 لان هناك هذه
كانت خارج الحسابات وهذا كان هناك حلفاء
مهددين كمبارك مثلا حين حدث هذا التهديد
كان هناك تصور انه يمكن ان يكون هناك تحول
ديمقراطي حقيقي في المنطقه وهو ما لم يحدث
يعني راينا الوضع باستثم
هل [__]
طعت المجتمع الدولي نسيم الولايات المتحده
بالنظر الشرح الذي شرحته بغض
النظر هذه الانتهاكات ويلا الى الدعم
نحن عدنا نعم الى مرحله ما قبل 2011 او
سبتمبر
سبتمبر 11 سبتمبر مرحله ان الان يوجد
تهديدات حقيقيه يوجد تصاعد وتنظيم الدوله
اذا نظرت الخطاب كاري اليوم هو يتكلم اكثر
الخطاب عن التهديدات الامنيه عن تنظيم
الدوله وعن ولايه سيناء وانصار بيت المقدس
وسماهم بالاسم وعن موالاتهم لتنظيم الدوله
وبالتالي الان من الذي سيواجههم نظام
عسكري قوي وبالتالي سيتم يعني الدعم لهذا
النظام كما انه حليف ايضا
شكرا على التوضيح اختم مع احمد مفرح اذا
على ما يبدو سيد احمد مفرح الولايات
المتحده كما شرح لنا الضيف من لندن هذا
وضعها هل وضع الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا برايك
نفس الشيء علما الاتحاد الاوروبي دائما ما
يتدرع مساله حقوق الانسان في علاقاته
وحواراته مع الدول هل ايضا اتحاد الاوروبي
نفس الموقف وما الحل كيف يمكن وقف في ظل
هذا الوضع كله كله
يعني دعينا نفرق ما بين السياسه وما بين
المجتمع المدني نحن كمنظمات مجتمع مدني
حقوق الانسان نتعامل بشكل مباشر مع
المجتمع المدني
الدولي والمحلي وغيره من من المجتمعات
المدنيه الاخرى المهتمه بشكل كبير
بالاحوال في مصر او في الشرق الاوسط عموما
وبالتالي فحينما نتحدث عن المجتمع نتحدث
ايضا عن المجتمع الدولي الخاص بحقوق
الانسان وهو مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعه
للامم المتحده وغيره من الاليات الدوليه
التي من المفترض على الحكومه المصريه ان
تقوم وان تبذل بتعهداتها وبمعاهداتها التي
وقعت عليها ان تقوم بتصديقها على ارض
الواقع بدلا من ان تقوم بتجذبها وان تقوم
بتكذيب الاوضاع التي نقوم بالعمل عليها
مثلا واشنطن تقول في افتتاحيتها مستر
كارني
يعني قول الحقيقه هذا امر في غايه الاهميه
حينما يتم حينما يتم التعامل مع الاوضاع
في مصر بشكل بشكل عملي وبشكل اظهار
للحقائق التي للاسف الشديد يخفيها الكثير
من المثقفين والعلماء والحكومه المصريه
بالطبع تعمل على هذا الامر فهذا يساعد
كثيرا ويساعدنا نحن كم انسان ويساعد
الضحايا ذاتهم في ان نبرز وان نوضح ما
تتعرض وهم يتعرض للمواطنين المصريين في
مصر يوميا من الانتهاكات سواء كانت متعلقه
بالحقوق المدنيه والسياسيه او المتعلقه
بالحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه شكرا
جزيلا لك من اسطنبول احمد مفرح نتحدث باسم
منظمه الكرامه لحقوق الانسان ايضا اشكر من
لندن عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والعلوم السياسيه في الجامعات البريطانيه
وايضا اشكر الدكتور حسن نافعه استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه القاهره واشكر
متابعتكم الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]